Trump bands nearly all travel to and
from Europe the NBA suspends its season
and Tom Hanks comes down with
coronavirus I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn my savvy fans
secure their internet join them in
expressvpn comm slash bet all right so
last night President Trump basically
said to coronavirus I'm in control here
and coronavirus said to do for you in
control so things are not going great
out there with the coronavirus the big
problem of course continued lack of
information the testing kits are not
widely available we just don't know how
many people in the United States
actually have coronavirus we don't even
know how many people abroad have thrown
a virus what we do know is that there
are certain measures that have been
taken the harsher the measures it seems
the faster the corona virus is brought
under control this is true in wuhan it
was true in South Korea where you've
seen a significant bending of the curve
that is what people are calling it the
curve being the number of people who are
infected and then the number of people
who are dying this obviously means that
people are now getting increasingly
serious and cautious about going to wide
scale public events not that if you're
young and you go to a big public event
you're gonna die but that if you go to a
public event you may become a carrier or
transmitter to somebody who is more
vulnerable somebody with a pre-existing
condition somebody who doesn't have a
strong immune system cancer patients
leukemia patients people who are older
right all of this is is deeply
frightening I mean there's no other way
to put it you look at the news it's hard
not to be scared and the reason it's
hard not to be scared is when you see
Italy shutting down every public space
like all public spaces except for
grocery stores and pharmacies no church
services going on in Italy no stores
open in Italy when you see Israel
shutting down not only I'll travel but
all public events over 100 people when
you see people trying to shut down
public events in Washington State
obviously all of this is predicated on
the notion that coronavirus is easily
transmitted which as far as we know is
true and also that coronavirus is a lot
more deadly than the flu which as far as
we know is also true but it does differ
based on age bracket it is irresponsible
reporting to suggest that every person
who who takes gets coronavirus is
equally likely to die of it or
experience significant ramifications
from corona virus the younger you are
the better chance you have of recovering
from this end even if you're older the
majority
the people who are getting it are indeed
recovering the death rates even for
people above 80 yes it's like 15% which
is unbelievably high really frightening
but that means that 85% of the people
getting it above the age of 80 are
recovering from coronavirus but it is
lack of information that of course is
scaring the living hell out of everyone
and this means that President Trump
stepping into the fray and presenting
some sort of plan here was he absolutely
necessary President Trump did that last
night he got some mixed reviews let's
put it that way but first let's get to
the actual news of yesterday the World
Health Organization declared a pandemic
of coronavirus disease covered 19
according to the Washington Post the
w-h-o declared coronavirus a pandemic
reflecting alarm that countries aren't
working quickly and aggressively enough
to fight the disease it causes kovin 19
they are deeply concerned by both the
alarming levels of spread in severity
and at the alarming levels of inaction
said whu-oh director general Ted Rose at
Hunnam capita Asus for weeks now the
w-h-o has hesitated to make a pandemic
declaration for fear of inciting panic
or prompting some countries to flag in
their efforts even though many
epidemiologists believe the corona virus
had already spread to pandemic levels
but on Wednesday Ted Rose noted the
widespread scale of the outbreak said
there are now more than 118 thousand
cases in 114 countries over 4,000 people
40 291 in that count have lost their
lives in the days and weeks ahead we
expect to see the number of coronavirus
cases and the number of deaths and the
number of affected countries climb even
higher Tedrow said that the word
pandemic is not a word to be used
lightly or carelessly it's a word that
if misused can cause unreasonable fear
or unjustified acceptance that the fight
is over leading to unnecessary suffering
and death the WH o--'s announcement does
not trigger any new funding protocols or
regulations it basically just scares the
living hell out of everyone is what you
get from that it's not that anybody then
gets a release of funding thanks to like
if you declare a national emergency in
the United States that gives additional
powers to the government that's not the
same thing for the WH out when they
declare a pandemic it basically has the
same effect as Michael Scott going to
the center of the office and shouting I
declare bankruptcy
like okay thanks super helpful okay with
that said the NBA has now put its season
on hold after one player tested positive
for coronavirus we're now finding out
that a second player has tested positive
for a corona virus according to the LA
Times the NBA on Wednesday indefinitely
spended the 2019 2020 season after Utah
Jazz Center Rudy Gobert tested positive
for Kovan 19 just a couple of days ago
Gobert who apparently was coughing in
the locker room he jokingly went around
the press room and started touching
everything like it's a joke he started
touching all the microphones he started
touching all the reporters stuff well
turns out dude had coronavirus and now
it turns out that another player has
come down with coronavirus as well
according to the league the test result
was reported shortly prior to the
tip-off of tonight's game between the
Jazz and Oklahoma City Thunder at
Chesapeake Energy Arena at that time
tonight's game was canceled the affected
player was not in the arena the NBA is
suspending gameplay following the
conclusion of tonight's schedule of
games until further notice so we're now
living inside Space Jam if you remember
the plot of space champ
all the players refused to play because
they are afraid that they're gonna be
infected with the alien virus locker
room the NBA will use this hiatus to
determine next steps for moving forward
in regard to the corona virus pandemic
Mark Cuban who's the owner of the Dallas
Mavericks he came out yesterday he said
that he's going to try and find a way to
continue paying his hourly employees
which is a really cool thing to do
obviously the Lakers and Clippers were
considered favors for the championship
the Lakers landed in China for
exhibition games after an international
incident this was just the end of last
year Lakers employees are being advised
to work from home for the foreseeable
future the Clippers will not practice on
Thursday meanwhile we're now finding out
that Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson have
tested positive for coronavirus which is
always good news and by good news I mean
just ridiculous and horrifying so even
celebrities co-wrote coronavirus falls
on the on the blessed and the unblessed
alike as first reported by deadline the
Academy Award winner and his wife were
on location in Australia for
pre-production of a film on Elvis
Presley when they began experiencing
symptoms Hank's wrote in a statement
first published by deadline and later
shared to Twitter we felt a bit tired
like we had colds we had some body aches
Rita had some chills that came and went
slight fevers - to play things right as
is needed in the world right now we were
tested for coronavirus and were found to
be positive Hank's went on to say that
he and Wilson will be tested observed
and isolated for as long as Public
Health and Safety require it meanwhile
as I mentioned we we now have a breaking
piece of news that jazz star Donovan
Mitchell has tested positive for
coronavirus as well jazz players
privately say that Rudy Gobert had been
clicked
Carolus in the locker room touching
other players and their belongings as
well so that's scary stuff Reuters is
reporting the president geiger bowls and
arrow of Brazil is being tested for
coronavirus we know the Health Minister
of Great Britain has coronavirus so this
thing is it is widespread it is it is
hitting a lot of people yeah it would
not be surprising to me that if
universal testing were available in the
United States hundreds of thousands of
people would have coronavirus already
that would not be shocking at all the
Brazilian government spokesman who met
with President Trump last weekend it was
pictured standing next to him has now
tested positive for coronavirus as well
so you would hope that the president in
the United States has been tested for
coronavirus the Brazilian presidents as
I mentioned is now being monitored for
coronavirus his schedule for the week
was canceled
both were with donald trump and mike
pence last saturday at mar-a-lago as
well so all of this is um all of this is
deeply disturbing we're going to get to
more of this in just one second and
president Trump's response which as I
say is receiving at best a mixed reviews
and frankly those mixed reviews are well
deserved we'll get to that in just one
second first if you want to give a truly
meaningful gift this season
get yourself a beautiful portrait now I
know that sounds like it's gonna cost
you a fortune is gonna be supremely
expensive but here is the truth it isn't
over at paint your life calm fantastic
fantastic gifts available to you we have
a paint your life portrait of my family
me my wife two of our three kids hanging
over our mantel right now I can't wait
to get our next one once we have a
portrait of all of the kids that'll just
be fantastic you can have an original
painting of yourself your children your
family a special place to cherish pet at
a price you can afford from paint your
life calm it's a true painting it's done
by hand by a world-class artist created
from a favorite photo it makes the
perfect gift for birthdays anniversaries
or special family holidays you choose
the artist and then you work with that
artist to get it exactly where you want
it to be there's no risk if you don't
love the final painting your money is
then refunded with paint your life you
get your favorite memories transformed
into a work of art that will be seen
every day and cherished forever
again that portrait it makes me brighten
up every time I walk into my house
seeing my kids right now as a limited
time offer I get 30% off your painting
that is correct 30% off and free
shipping to get this special offer text
the word been to 64,000 that has been
through 64000 text been bien to 64,000
okay so meanwhile New York all of the
big New York live shows
going to be airing without any live
audiences according to media height
concerns about coronavirus have led to a
number of daytime show's taping without
audiences now late night is doing the
same the view taped yesterday without an
audience which basically mirrors reality
but in any case The Hollywood Reporter
is now saying that The Late Show with
Colbert Tonight Show with Fallon Late
Night with Seth Meyers Daily Show with
Trevor Noah full-frontal Samantha bee
last week tonight without John Oliver
all will be proceeding without audiences
also Fox News has confirmed that the
Greg Gutfeld show is dropping in to
audience as well so everybody is cutting
down on the audience's the NCAA
tournament is now going to be played
without fans in a statement posted on
Wednesday afternoon the NCAA President
Mark Emmert announced the upcoming
championship events including the men's
and women's basketball tournaments will
be played in front of only essential
staff and limited family as well Emmett
wrote while I understand how
disappointing this is for all the fans
of our sports my decision is based on
the current understanding of how Coppa
19 is progressing in the United States
this decision is in the best interest of
Public Health including that of coaches
administrators fans and most importantly
our student-athletes the men's final
four was slated to take place before a
sellout crowd in probably seventy
thousand people at mercedes-benz Stadium
in Atlanta as well meanwhile New York
City has canceled the st. Patrick's Day
Parade that is no shock at all I'd
predicted that a little bit earlier this
week although bill de blasio said on
Monday there were no plans to cancel the
parade the parade has now been canceled
there are now 53 known cases of covered
19 in New York City the answer is
probably a lot lot higher parent-teacher
conferences of public schools have been
canceled and Andrew Cuomo announced on
Wednesday that all of the SUNY and CUNY
schools will switch to remote learning
now one of the big controversies right
now is whether there should be
widespread school shutdowns
the case in favor of widespread school
shutdowns is that the kids are basically
germ factories they're gonna be passing
this stuff to each other then they go
home and they bring it to mom and dad
who bring it to grandparents that is the
case for shutting down the schools
schools are germ factories the case for
not shutting down the schools is kids or
germ factories you bring them home from
school what exactly do you do with them
all day and a lot of people don't have
child care if you send them to a daycare
it's the same thing and sending them to
a school if they're home they're more
likely in touch with other members of
their family so it's not really a
cure-all it is unclear whether school
shutdowns are the best idea at this
point for schools that do not actually
have any incidents of coronavirus but
again because testing them coronavirus
is so scanty
it's difficult to tell who the hell even
has coronavirus at this point okay so
with with all of this said Anja Angela
Merkel in Germany is is telling the the
German people that 70 percent of the
population could come in contact with
coronavirus she said the consensus among
experts is that 60 to 70 percent of the
population will be infected as long as
this remains the situation she says that
we have to basically shut down all
social meetings we have to and no more
handshakes we have to get we really have
to change our lives in significant ways
in order prevent this sort of widespread
spread of coronavirus and that makes
perfect sense I mean remember right now
we're just buying time right that's what
this is about this is not that
coronavirus will disappear if we all
take two weeks off the idea here is that
you're buying time you're slowing the
spread that every day that you add to
that curve means a day that researchers
are able to develop a vaccine is the day
that brings us closer to summer there's
a lot of speculation that during warm
weather seasons the flu tends to die out
and so if we can get into summer and
warm weather in the northern hemisphere
that that will help curb the spread of
coronavirus in general we can all pray
and hope for that bottom line is that
everybody is rightly at this point
worried about coronavirus because we do
not have enough information and a lot of
that has to do with lack of testing that
is the fault of the federal government
it is the fault of state governments we
talked yesterday about the fact that
even local testing in Seattle was shut
down by the FDA and the CDC all of this
has resulted in the Dow Jones Industrial
Average absolutely collapsing yesterday
the Dow ended its 11-year bull market as
coronavirus defied economic remedies all
this talk about how we're going to solve
this thing by pumping the economy full
of money that's not right people are not
spending people are not going out in
public places they shouldn't be spending
they shouldn't be going out and hanging
out in public places so of course you're
gonna see an economic contraction when
everybody stays home there's an economic
contraction that is not a great shock
now what you would expect is that once
coronavirus is under control no matter
what you would see a v-shaped recovery
because the underlying economic
fundamentals are not really the problem
the problem right now is that is that
nobody knows what is coming and that
uncertainty is being priced into the
market suffice it to say the Dow Jones
Industrial Average is taking the
absolute beating it took a beating
yesterday it was down 1,400 points
yesterday it opened this morning
down 2,000 points so it is dropped down
well below 22,000 it is it is headed
toward 21,000 right now and just
remember folks that when Barack Obama
left office the Dow Jones Industrial
Average was in the neighborhood of about
20,000 is about nineteen thousand eight
hundred we are now at 21,000 twenty one
thousand five hundred so we are
approaching the point where all stock
market gains under President Trump have
been lost
thanks to coronavirus alone which is an
amazing amazing statement about
globalization and the cost of
globalization the benefits of
globalization are there for everybody to
see the cost of globalization are if you
have a Black Swan event like this one it
can completely shut down supply lines
all over the globe and the Dow Jones is
collapsed today does demonstrate that
president Trump's attempts last night to
tamp this thing down were a failure at
least in the public mind hey there there
is no sense of confidence that is
emanating from the federal government
there isn't this does not mean that the
federal government could at this point
do anything that would tamp down the
markets like bottom line is that even if
Trump had done a stellar job last night
which he did not even if Trump had done
a stellar job last night it is unlikely
that the markets wouldn't have dropped
this morning because again he can't
provide assurances that everything is
under control cuz everything isn't under
control we don't know exactly what the
hell is happening right now I mean the
fact is that Italy has shut down all
life there and the deaths continue to
rise in Italy so we're gonna bring you
more of this in just one second we'll
get you president Trump's response
yesterday which was marred by a bunch of
screw-ups unfortunately we'll get to
that momentarily first let us talk about
protecting your online activity so
here's the reality if you're spending
the next two weeks self florins yuning
well you're probably can be online a lot
and you know what that is a boon for
hackers people who are looking for your
data you should be using a VPN I use a
VPN even if you're using incognito mode
that doesn't really protect you ISPs can
still see your entire browsing history
and of course they can also sell this
information to tech giant's as well
expressvpn also encrypt 100% of your
data with the best-in-class encryption
so your information is always protected
even when you're using public Wi-Fi like
at a cafe or a hotel expressvpn works on
everything phones laptops routers
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can still
be protected even if they don't have
Express VPN if you're not using a VPN
and somebody steals your data kind of
your fault a little bit at this point
protect your online activity today but
the VPN I trust to secure my privacy
visit
special link and expressvpn comm / ben
you can get an extra three months for
free on a one-year package that is e^x
PR ESS VPN comm / Ben expressvpn comm /
Ben to learn more again its expressive
VPN comm / Ben hey so president Trump
spoke last night on coronavirus whoever
whoever greenlit this bleep show should
be fired I mean seriously it's not in
it's not entirely Trump's fault because
again he has speech writers who do this
thing for him let's put this way this
thing started with Donald Trump on
c-span saying the F word okay and
because he had an ink stain on his shirt
that is never a good way to start this
thing he do not make the cameras live
you morons until the president is ready
to speak then President Trump got on air
and he spoke about coronavirus it did
not settie the markets it didn't make
people feel a lot more secure he was
getting serious about it there's a lot
better than President Trump going out in
public and suggesting there were 15
cases and it was moving down to zero as
he did a couple of weeks ago which was
obviously untrue but with that said here
was the President of the United States
last night announcing we are marshalling
the full force of the American
government today the World Health
Organization officially announced that
this is a global pandemic we have been
in frequent contact with our allies and
we are marshalling the full power of the
federal government and the private
sector to protect the American people
this is the most aggressive and
comprehensive effort to confront a
foreign virus in modern history okay
well there is only one problem which is
that he didn't actually get to the the
key points of the speech so here's what
he announced he announced that we're
suspending all travel from Europe to the
United States there's one problem with
that we are not in fact suspending all
travel from Europe to the United States
he can still get in if you aren't coming
in from the UK also it turns out that if
you're an American citizen overseas if
you're a soldier overseas you can come
home he didn't make that clear so a lot
of people overseas we're rushing to buy
plane tickets hoping to sneak in under
the deadline sort of shades of the
original travel ban that President Trump
issued when he first came into office
that was a debacle in the way that it
was originally instituted if you were
going to give a speech like this you
have to have everything locked down
you're trying to provide a sense of
solidity you're trying to provide a
sense that you know what you're doing
that the federal
from it has thought these policies out
fully and that they are providing
detailed guidance to people well
president Trump was serious about
coronavirus which again is a good thing
but when you give a speech like this you
got to make sure that everything is
locked down it was not locked down here
as president Trump suggesting that all
travel from Europe is going to be
suspended to keep new cases from
entering our shores we will be
suspending all travel from Europe to the
United States for the next 30 days the
new rules will go into effect Friday at
midnight these restrictions will be
adjusted subject to conditions on the
ground there will be exemptions for
Americans who have undergone appropriate
screenings and these prohibitions will
not only apply to the tremendous amount
of Trade and cargo but various other
things as we get approval anything
coming from Europe to the United States
is what we are discussing ok so that is
not true okay so that is mistake number
two okay mistake number two is that he
announced that there would be basically
bans on the importation of European
goods which would shut down the entire
global economy and the stock market was
like what the f is this and it turns out
of course that his executive order does
no such thing it doesn't apply to trade
and goods it apply only it applies to
humans because if you buy something from
Europe it is not as though the virus is
coming over on your food thing from
Europe so announcing apparently accident
I means in the teleprompter so I'm not
sure how that's an accident whoever put
that in the teleprompter needs to be
fired forthwith that the prohibitions
will not only apply to the tremendous
amount of trading cargo but various
other things as we get approval the
White House then had to clarify saying
that the ban only applies to human
beings not goods or cargo the people
transporting goods will not be admitted
into the country but the goods will and
then president Trump had to go on
Twitter and correct himself he said
please remember very important for all
countries and businesses to know trade
will in no way be affected by the 30-day
restriction on travel from Europe the
restriction stops people not good it's
also important to note when he says
30-day to restriction the executive
order does not have a 30-day timeline so
it could be extended beyond 30 days also
Trump didn't mention that the ban would
not apply to American residents citizens
or generally citizens immediate family
members and the DHS the Department of
Homeland Security had to issue a
statement making that clear okay then
President Trump announced
that health insurance providers had
agreed to waive customer payments for
coronavirus treatment he said earlier
this week I met with the leaders of
health insurance industry who have
agreed to waive all co-payments for
coronavirus treatments extend insurance
coverage to these treatments and to
prevent surprise at medical billing but
that's not true
they met with Trump and they said we'll
make the corona virus testing free it is
a very different thing from coronavirus
treatment if you get double pneumonia as
a result of coronavirus insurance
companies can't make that free exactly
how are they going to survive that
without some sort of federal government
bailout a White House official confirmed
to CNN that insurers had only agreed to
waive co-payments on testing not the not
the actual cost of the treatment itself
then President Trump attacked the
European Union saying that large numbers
of clusters in the US had been seeded by
European travelers means some of that is
true but the fact is that we are not
even sure whether banning travel from
Europe at this point is going to be
incredibly effective considering that we
now have community infection in the
United States so well it may be a good
idea to prevent further travel generally
because travel is basically people in
small enclosed spaces with lots of other
people with that said the idea that a
travel shut down at this point is gonna
be completely effective it was effective
originally now that the virus is
widespread it's difficult to imagine how
that's going to be completely effective
in the United States we can't even trace
where the cases are coming from right
now we have community infections hey
president Trump did announce that the
Small Business Administration will prove
up be providing fifty billion dollars in
small business loans one of the problems
with with this particular policy is that
how do you determine which small
businesses ought to get the loans in the
first place once the government becomes
the lender of last resort to businesses
you're picking and choosing winners in a
way that other policies would not a
payroll tax holiday would not pick and
choose winners if the federal government
were frankly to just give everybody
$1,000 Andrew yang style that would not
be picking and choosing winners but
instead to to use the SBA to sort of
prop up particular businesses but not
other businesses unless it's universal
it's very difficult to see how this is
going to work there's president from
talking about the Small Business
Administration I am instructing the
Small Business Administration to
exercise available authority to provide
capital and liquidity to firms affected
by the corona virus effective
immediately
the SBA will begin providing
economic loans in affected states and
territories these low-interest loans
will help small businesses overcome
temporary economic disruptions caused by
the virus to this end I am asking
Congress to increase funding for this
program by an additional 50 million
dollars okay so you know we'll see
whether that is effective or not bottom
line is that there's gonna have to be
some government response to the fact
that there gonna be a lot of short-term
layoffs people being furloughed from
work thanks to all of this it would not
be surprising for the federal government
to step in okay we're gonna get to the
media's response to Trump because Trump
speech had serious problems he did not
look good doing it
he made some real mistakes in the middle
of the speech but the media's response
is overwhelmingly stupid like incredibly
an overwhelmingly stupid we're gonna get
to that in just one moment first let's
talk about how you can make your
business more efficient obviously you
got to be on top of your data very
important for you to be on top of your
data that is the only way to ensure that
you know where your efficiencies and
inefficiencies lie what do companies
like wring hint into Kovas all have in
common they all use NetSuite to
accelerate their growth successful
companies know that in order to grow
faster you have to have the right tools
if you want to take your company from 2
million to 10 million or 10 million to
hundreds of millions in revenue
NetSuite by Oracle gives you the tools
to turbocharge your growth with NetSuite
you get a full picture of your business
finance inventory HR customers and more
it's everything you need to grow all in
one place directly from your phone or
computer
NetSuite will give you the visibility
and control you need to make the right
decisions and grow with confidence
that's why NetSuite customers grow
faster than the S&P 500 NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
trusted by more than 19,000 companies
it's the last system they're ever going
to need go check them out right now at
NetSuite NetSuite comm slash apparel
gives you a free product tour and
receive your free guide six ways to run
a more profitable business at NetSuite
comm slash of Shapiro that is any TSU i
te comm slash Shapiro NetSuite comm
slash up here oh that's NetSuite dot-com
slash Shapiro ok so president Trump's
speech as I mentioned has some serious
problems with the with you know in
general with that said this it's good
that the president is now taking it
seriously because his prior response has
been insufficient and I've pointed this
out the president has been giving very
mixed messages on Twitter in public
about the nature of coronavirus about
how much of a threat it is okay so he is
getting more serious
about all this without question and it
is true that the administration's
response
put-put trump aside the administration's
response has been quite serious and the
fact is that that Stephen Redd who is
one of the Trump key officials on all of
this
Stephen Redd suggested yesterday that
the coronavirus response is
significantly larger than the American
response to h1n1 which was a major
epidemic that happened in 2009 it's a
much larger response than we had for
h1n1 I think there are more sectors of
government involved we didn't do a lot
of the things that we're doing now
because they weren't appropriate the
border issues we had cases here that the
the pandemic was first recognized in the
United States so that that's a totally
different situation okay so that
obviously is true red is by the way the
assistant Surgeon General he also
mentioned that president Trump's
original Chinese travel restrictions
were very useful and this happens to be
true here is Stephen Redd explaining
that China's travel restrictions were at
work correct I think that that was a
period of time when we were there's not
really anything we would have done
differently we were working on a
diagnostic test we were sending
materials that started the ball rolling
on vaccine production we you know as you
know within weeks of of identifying the
outbreak really the restriction of
travel from China reduced travel by 90
percent I think that was a very helpful
move to prevent more cases from China
coming into the United States okay with
all of that said dr. Anthony foul she's
the head of National Institutes for
allergies and infectious diseases he
says we have to crack down on large
crowds this is the next chief measure
again the administration is on top of
this to the extent that any federal
administration is on top of it the
problem has been the disconnect for
Trump so Trump getting serious last
night was a good thing even if the
speech was a bit of a screw up here's
Anthony foul a yesterday saying no large
crowds would be a good start
we would recommend that did not be large
crowds if that means not having any
people in the audience or the NBA plays
so be it
but as a public health official anything
that has large crowds is something that
would give a risk to spread now there is
some good news
found she said we are reaching a stage
one vaccine faster than anyone has ever
reached a stage one vaccine so there's a
bit of good news for you with regard to
vaccines as I've mentioned publicly many
times we were able to very quickly go
from an understanding of what this virus
was to what the genetic sequence was to
actually developing a vaccine but
there's a lot of confusion about
developing a vaccine in the next I would
say four weeks or so we will go into
what is called a phase 1 clinical trial
getting it into phase 1 in a matter of
months is the quickest that anyone has
ever done literally in the history of X
and ology members of the government are
also pointing out that while we are
ramping up for widespread testing it's
gonna take another two weeks for
widespread testing which that of course
is bad news that means more
informational deficits at this point all
of which is is bad news now as I say the
media's response to all of this has been
absolutely egregious I don't just mean
like criticism of Trump that all of that
is fair you know if President President
Trump has to handle this better his
speech was not good okay he said in his
oval office speech the vast majority of
Americans the risk is very very low but
that not the risk of actually getting it
the risk of dying I mean that that
particularly is true with with all of
that said the the president also is
getting criticized and here's where the
media have really gone off the rails
President Trump last night said that
this is the the major government
response to a foreign virus it's the
largest foreign major response to a
foreign virus and this immediately led
people in the media to whine about the
fact that Trump had said that the wuhan
virus is in fact a foreign virus okay I
have a question why is that a big deal
it is a foreign virus why is that a
problem is that an element of xenophobia
like seriously this is why your this is
what you're focused on you're focused on
the fact that Trump points out that
another major virus comes from China and
that maybe this might have some
implications for American policy and
your initial takeaway is that that's
Trump being a racist against Chinese
people that that's really where you're
going with us I'm sorry I'm not gonna
consider you a serious person if you
think it's a major problem for the
President of the United States to point
out that a foreign virus is indeed a
foreign virus literally the entire media
two months ago was calling this the Wu
hen virus anyway here is the brothers
Cuomo Chris and Andrew
interviewing Andrew Cuomo governor of
New York about all this and Governor
Cuomo very angry that Trump called the
virus foreign this is not about a
foreign virus whatever that means it's
here it's community spread it's much
more prevalent than we know the testing
does not reflect what it is these are
not random sample tests it's because we
have no testing capacity that's why the
numbers are low if you actually had
testing capacity you would see how high
the numbers are already okay so it is
true that we need better testing
capacity but if you're really bitching
at this point about calling it a foreign
by risk your priorities are completely
and utterly misplaced I mean that is a
disaster and and you've seen additional
media stupidity Don Lemon on CNN today
or last night he's on John Kasich Kasich
is no friend of President Trump I mean
John Kasich hates President Trump and
John Kasich was on and he said like I
thought that the president did okay
like it was fine his speech was fine and
Don Lemon lost his mind lost his mind
this is your media this is your very
objective media here's Don Lemon going
after John Kasich John the governor's
can't make choices they can't if there
are no test kits if the test kits that
the the federal government has promised
aren't out there then those governors
can't make choices and you said that
listen the president you said the
president's just stick to the script
I don't know if he stuck to the script
or not but that whatever script he read
I was wrong because they've had to
clarify it several times I just got to
say it the president came out to call
people's fears he didn't do a good job
of it because they'd had to come back
and clarify it several times and if this
has been going on tonight for them to
get it straight we need straight
actually donation from this president
and this administration and we're not
getting it and I don't understand why
you are tiptoeing around it he came out
gave an address that old that usually it
happens very rarely and he doesn't get
it right I'm gonna tell you first of all
he read it and somebody that wrote this
look I don't want to get into that he
was he says can I finish and Don Lemon
says no you can't finish because Don
Lemon has an agenda here and the agenda
is to paint Trump
obviously incompetent and terrible at
everything again there are real problems
with the speech but let's be real about
this the speech is not the problem the
problem is lack of information okay what
the president says makes a difference
but the markets were not going to
respond well anyway to the fact that we
have a tremendous lack of information
the president is obviously on a personal
level taking everything a lot more
seriously that the president is meeting
with a prime minister today and they
agreed not to shake hands and Trump said
it's a strange feeling for politicians
because handshaking is routine but again
the media have an agenda here their
agenda is to paint Trump as like several
things can be told once one Trump is not
doing the world's best job of handling
this thing on a personal level to the
Trump administration is doing everything
that it can and they're doing just as
much as any other administration would
Anthony foul she has served in several
different administrations and governors
like Gavin Newsom from California are
saying they're getting what they need
from it the federal government three
nobody has this thing under control and
for the media wants to see Trump fall
flat on his face and they are eager to
paint Trump as unable to handle this
whole thing so all of those things can
be true at once and in fact all of those
things are true at once in just a second
we're gonna get to more media
malfeasance the media really really
trying to play up the idea that the
federal government's response is not
only insufficient but uniquely
insufficient because Trump because
everything is Trump I'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
making your house look more beautiful
hey you're gonna be in it for a little
while longer it seems seems like you may
be spending some more time at home well
whether you're at home take a look at
those window coverings those look good
to you yeah don't look at me either
pretty ugly instead what you need a
really nice set of blinds making your
home more beautiful is actually easy and
affordable with blinds.com it's the
number one online retailer of custom
window treatments whether you want them
to handle everything with their new
measure and install services or you want
to do it yourself you'll enjoy the
blinds.com treatment and get sell it
early cellular shades wood blinds
plantation shutters and pretty much any
known window treatment on the planet at
blinds.com every single order gets free
samples free shipping and it's truly
free to talk to a professional designer
blinds.com has no hidden fees no
misleading quotes unlike some other
places plus their 100% satisfaction
guarantee means if you're not totally
satisfied with the style color or
quality of your window treatments
blinds.com
will remake them for free so head on
over to blinds.com for the best quality
window treatments at low prices for a
limited time my listeners save fifteen
percent or more plus
an extra 20 bucks off with promo code
been save fifteen percent or more on the
best looking blinds shades and shutters
plus an extra $20 off at blinds.com with
promo code been blinds comm promo club
Ben rules and restrictions do apply
meanwhile time is running out to get
twenty five percent off all daily wire
memberships with coupon code never
socialist get me home for a while well
why don't you just tap into all of our
content the deal ends on Friday don't
hesitate any longer
unlike Bernie we know when to stop a
campaign so hurry and get 25% off all
daily wear memberships well at last
daily where our members get an ad-free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcast and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
access to the mailbag and now exclusive
election insight op-eds from yours truly
daily where members also get to ask us
questions during backstage our all new
all accessed here allows you to join in
live online queue aides with me and the
other hosts along with all of this of
course you get the magnificent
irreplaceable singular left is tears
tumbler if you haven't already go
download our daily we're app so you can
get all of our great content on the go
again that is 25% off on daily water
memberships for all plans using coupon
code never socialists so head on over to
daily wire.com slash subscribe unlike
hillary this deal will be going away so
act now before ends on Friday that's
daily wire.com slash subscribe
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so president Trump obviously
getting raked over the coals so is Mike
Pence Mike Pence did a did a segment
with Alison Cammarata in which she was
going after him really hard this is the
role of the media is to ask very
difficult questions of the Trump
administration in the most unfair
possible ways and also to play on the
gap between Trump's personal
thin-skinned Ness and the members of his
administration right this is this is
something that the media have learned to
play and play this game really well and
that is if you're a member of the Trump
administration and from says something
dumb you're not allowed to go on TV and
just say yeah the president shouldn't
said that or yeah the president didn't
mean that you're not allowed to do that
because then Trump gets mad at you and
so what the media have decided to do is
basically hold every member of the Trump
administration to account for anything
done the president says well this is
what Allison camerado was doing today
with Mike Pence and it got pretty ugly
president Trump's speech last night
after he talked about the travel ban
from Europe or travel restrictions I
guess I should say from Europe and the
handling of cargo shipments two
clarifications basically had to be
issued within the space of an hour one
from DHS saying that the travel
restrictions do not apply to all travel
and then the President himself tweeted
he didn't mean cargo so so why the
confusion I don't think there was
confusion the the president took another
historic step just like he did in
January with China to suspend all travel
from Europe
Allisyn for the next 30 days because
we've recognized our health experts
tracking global data that the epicenter
of the coronavirus has shifted from
China and South Korea to Europe okay so
again this is being trotted around the
media as evidence that pence won't talk
up to Trump okay look we all know the
situation here the situation is that the
president has personal character flaws
when it comes to being thin-skinned he
doesn't want anybody in his
administration contradicting him and
Trump isn't the guy who wrote the speech
or loaded the teleprompter listen the
the buck stops with the with the
president with that said again whoever
put that crap and teleprompter needs to
be fired like forth
really you put an error ridden speech in
the middle of a global pandemic and the
president's teleprompter you ought to be
fired like seriously somebody needs
there are some heads that need to roll
now we should be in the business not of
looking for a head rolling at this point
but we should be in the business of
seeing what the response ought to look
like and right now the answer is nobody
knows what the hell the response ought
to look like what we do know is that
pumping is not going to be the solution
president Trump has been fixated to this
point on the stock market and he
continues to be fixated on the stock
market today he was talking about how
the stock market is gonna be just fine
maybe it will but only in response to an
underlying ease in terms of what we know
about coronavirus right now people are
blaming this on Trump right Trump's
response to coronavirus that's why the
stock market is dropping no the the
reality is what people were looking for
from the president last night was a
reassurance everything was under control
Trump can't give that reassurance
because no one can the Prime Minister of
Italy can't do it the Prime Minister of
Israel can't do it the prime minister of
Ireland can't do it nobody that the head
of the w-h-o can't do it
what would Trump have said last night
that really would have called market
seriously the answer is nothing
if Trump had said okay you know we're
gonna do tomorrow we're shutting down
all public gatherings across the nation
we're gonna request nobody go to an
event with more than a hundred people
what do you think the stock market would
have done this morning it would've
dumped it was gonna dump anyway there's
not enough information out there so
that's not Trump's fault with that said
president Trump's bizarre notion that if
the Fed just eases money that somehow
the stock market's gonna be propped up
if we go to negative interest rates that
we're somehow gonna prop up the market
no one is spending no one is going out
you have a serious underlying problem if
no one is consuming then there's nobody
who's actually going to be hiring and if
nobody is hiring there's going to be a
lack of people who are capable of buying
things we're entering recession
territory we are now there are certain
things that can be done to stop gap this
thing right we can't have as we
mentioned a payroll tax holiday there
have been conservatives urging the
federal government to basically sign
unemployment checks for people who are
unemployed for the period that
coronavirus requires you to stay home
we've had we've had talked about paid
sick leave there's fairly wide
bipartisan support for a lot of these
proposals at least in the short term
because in emergencies an emergency that
but but with that said you know all of
the blame being cast on Trump it's too
much it's too much like Trump certainly
could have handled this better he
continues to need to hand
was better but the suggestion that Trump
is not taking this seriously right now
is ridiculous Jim Acosta tried this
yesterday Jim Acosta from CNN asked him
specifically if he was taking the
seriously enough and Trump ended him
okay so there he is ending Jim Acosta
meanwhile the media trying to prop up
Joe Biden as the alternative remember
they're always political political
ramifications for all of this a month
ago President Trump was on a solid path
to reelection is running against an an
old crone socialist but named Bernie
Sanders the stock market was at 29,000
and president from was leading in all
the swing states now the stock market is
at 21,000 Bernie Bernie Sanders is out
of the race and President Trump is
tweeting things okay so things change
fast in politics according to the New
York Times Joe Biden seeking a contrast
with Trump will speak today on
coronavirus so he's going to take to the
microphones to try and show why he would
be a better president than the president
and presumably he will get all sorts of
rich rewarding media coverage even if he
can't actually say the word coronavirus
properly because he is malfunctioning a
day after President Trump addressed the
Nation about coronavirus amid criticism
he has minimized the threat of the
pandemic according to the New York Times
Joe Biden plans to give his own remarks
on the virus seeking to project
steadiness and resolve from his purchase
frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination his campaign announced its
plans for the speech on Tuesday before
it from say oval office address Abidin
official described the upcoming remarks
is offering a view into how Biden will
lead in times of crisis as president
this is why president from botching that
speech last night was not only bad for
the country it was bad politically on
Wednesday his campaign announced the
formation of a public health advisory
committee so he's gonna run a shadow
government to prove that he will be more
competent than the President of the
United States members include Vivek
Murphy a former Surgeon General Ezekiel
Emanuel one of the architects of
Obamacare and Lisa Monaco who served as
homeland security and counterterrorism
advisor to Barack Obama Biden has
previously sketched out steps he would
take as president to fight that the
virus noting his work as VP and
combating Ebola
Biden has said he would insist on
transparency from China and has
expressed shock and frustration with
Trump's past skeptical remarks that is
the opening right you know that if this
thing deepens then all of the old
comments the president from
about the flu those are just gonna be
camp aid that those are just gonna be
campaign ad so Trump getting serious
about this is not only necessary it is
worthwhile okay again with all of that
said it is pretty clear that Joe Biden
is seeking to make hey the media are
seeking to make hey I've said for a long
time President Trump needs to run a
disciplined campaign if he wishes to win
the discipline extends to his actual
presidency and as worries grow as
celebrities get this thing as as
politicians and get this thing as it
seems as though we have no data then
calming presidential leadership is
necessary time like this calming is not
a thing that President Trump
tends to do now meanwhile there still as
the threat from inside the Democratic
House so the best case scenario for
President Trump is there's a v-shaped
recovery in a month month and a half
this thing calms down a little bit the
social distancing measures take effect
we have vaccines well on their way
summer hits and coronavirus diagnoses go
down the death rate is not as high as we
thought it was and then people buy up
the stock market I mean the fact is that
people like me if you're young you have
any sort of cash flow continuing to buy
into the stock market is a smart move
because eventually whether it's now or
six months from now or a year from now
the stock market is not only going to
recover it's going to start zooming
again okay and you're gonna make a lot
of money buying low and selling high is
the name of the game in the stock market
we haven't hit bottom yet Goldman Sachs
is suggesting we may drop another
fifteen percent on the stock market
which would put president Trump's stock
market below where it was when President
Trump took office again if you look at
the chart it's frightening I mean the
chart basically looks like continued
arithmetic growth in the stock market
and then boom right off a cliff
thanks to woo hand virus but the good
news is that that does not reveal
systemic failures of the American
government what that does or great
underlying weaknesses like in the in the
crash of 2007-2008 it just reveals a
major global pandemic disruption of the
system it's not the system itself so
that means that when the pandemic is
over or at least when it wanes or at
least when we think it's waning then
you're gonna see presumably a v-shaped
or u-shaped recovery the question is
whether that comes in time to help
President Trump if if it does then maybe
this thing is over by the time of the
election remember things change really
quickly in politics if we get to June
and things have waned on coronavirus and
President Trump takes significant action
which is what he should be doing right
now then he'll be in fairly good shape
he'll be able to say listen we did
everything we could
we stopped coronavirus in its tracks and
it won't be an issue by the
we hit october/november that's best case
scenario for President Trump
okay but that requires some pretty solid
leadership meanwhile inside the
Democratic Party the conflict continues
to play out between the Bernie Sanders
wing and then Joe Biden win yesterday
Bernie Sanders got up and he said I'm
not dropping out of this race no matter
what I'm gonna stick around he suggested
we are winning the debate but we're not
winning the electability debate which is
a very weird argument here is Bernie
Sanders yesterday announcing that he's
going to say in the race despite the
fact that he has no shot of winning the
nomination while our campaign has won
the ideological debate we are losing the
debate over electability I cannot tell
you how many people our campaign has
spoken to who have said and I quote I
like what your campaign stands for I
agree with what your campaign stands for
but I'm gonna vote for Joe Biden because
I think Joe is the best candidate to
defeat Donald Trump end of Court we have
heard that statement all over this
country needless to say I strongly
disagree with that assertion
okay so Bernie Sanders is not dropping
out he said he looks forward to debating
Joe Biden on Sunday look what is his
strategy he has no way of winning the
nomination
maybe his strategy is to stands in the
shadows and then as Joe Biden walks past
he just jumps out of the shadows go boom
and then something bad happens to Joe
Biden in capacity I don't know what
Bernie Sanders his strategy is for
winning combination it clearly is not
winning votes cuz he ain't gonna win any
votes nonetheless Sanders says he's
staying in he looks forward to debating
by and that's divided in the Democratic
Party if there is a recovery from
coronavirus which of course is top
priority for everybody if the country if
the world economy recovers the divide
between Sanders and Biden is gonna take
on a lot larger status as the election
approaches here's Sanders saying he
looks forward to debating Joe Biden for
no apparent reason
on Sunday I very much look forward to
the debate in Arizona with my friend Joe
Biden Donald Trump must be defeated and
I will do everything in my power to make
that happens on Sunday night in the
first one-on-one debate of this campaign
the American people will have the
opportunity to see which candidate is
best positioned to accomplish that goal
hey so that is where we currently stand
basically everything is on hold in
serious terms because of coronavirus but
a from a pastoral virus than all of the
political stuff is back on the table and
obviously it is true that coronavirus is
being politicized by people who are
looking for a political advantage
president Trump odd not hand people a
club with which state and politically
plus I mean he is that putting aside
politics for a second he's the leader of
the free world he's the leader of the
most powerful country on the planet he's
the leader of the country in which you
live competence is necessary calming is
necessary exactitude is necessary stop
with the Twitter crap stop with
downplaying the virus stop with
suggesting that the market is is gonna
be just fine bottom line is what we need
right now is solid concerted leadership
from the President of the United States
and his administration no slipshod crap
enough okay you live in the country I
live in the country we all want to see
this thing end also we all want to look
out for each other what we need right
now is a level of seriousness that I
think from started to evidence last
night it needs to continue forward and
he needs to not get caught up in all the
political back-and-forth with Democrats
people are not up for this anyway if the
Democrats decide to over politicize this
thing it will backfire on them and Trump
should know that Trump's job right now
is to lead he's the President of the
United States and he's been absolved
from a lot of the responsibilities of
leadership by the fact that we've
already baked into the cake that the
man's gonna tweet a lot but when you're
in the middle of a serious national or
international crisis like this there is
no substitute for leadership it's time
for the president to step up and get it
done okay time for a couple of things I
like and then a thing that I hate so as
long as they're gonna be self quarantine
I just restarted better call Saul so
better call Saul is a spinoff from
Breaking Bad if you've never seen
Breaking Bad go stream it that'll take a
couple of weeks and then they made a
spin-off called better call Saul which
is about one which is about the warrior
character in Breaking Bad I watched the
first season I thought it was fairly
good I started the second season
recently because I had heard that it got
better and it is indeed a fantastically
well-written show Vince Gilligan who's
behind the show is a tremendously
talented dude
so check out better call Saul here's the
trailer for season 1
you have meddled with the primal forces
of nature mr. Hamlin and I won't have it
what can we do for you Jimmy
what Chuck did for this firm one-third
of this place belongs to him if Chuck
can call this an extended sabbatical
then so can wait you know I'm gonna beat
this it's time to do right by him and
cash him out Hamlin's making you a chump
I'm going to get better Chuck I'm going
on here
come side of you okay so as long as
you're staying home the streaming
services are gonna do great by the way
go subscribe to daily where we're gonna
have lots of content to bring this
self-quarantine
period but better call Saul is
definitely worth the watch you can go
check that out today okay time for a
couple of things that I hate all righty
so a couple of things first Farhad
Manjoo has a really dumb column today
it's called the Republicans want
Medicare for all but just for this one
disease everyone's a socialist innama in
a pandemic
okay let's just be clear about something
even libertarians when it comes to
policing externalities when it comes to
collective action in the necessity of
fighting a collective threat are not
libertarians everyone knows this
okay libertarian principles do not apply
in wartime okay they're not a lot of
libertarians who think that we should
disband the US Army they're not a lot of
libertarians who believe that in a time
of pandemic we shouldn't collectively
mobilize and use the resources that are
at our disposal to prevent externalities
okay to that the idiocy is trying to
equate a pandemic situation with you
have a non communicable disease or you
have a disease that's not gonna kill
anybody else and when you're talking
about upend haven't seen this for years
okay I'm pretty libertarian when it
comes to vaccinations I do believe in
regulations at the school level that you
shouldn't be able to come to school
unless you are vaccinated why because
those have externalities that is not
anti libertarian only morons think that
a pandemic situation is the same thing
as you have cancer coverage through your
health insurance it's not Medicare for
all it's called shutting down
externalities the people that Reason
magazine wouldn't even argue with this
Charles W cook see W cook over at
National Review a libertarian is fully
on board with the idea of government
action in times of crisis like this when
there is a collect
threat to the collective because you
can't avoid the threat okay the the
idiocy of people on the left suggesting
that every situation is a crisis
situation and therefore medicare-for-all
is the same thing as taking care of the
population during a pandemic that's
nonsense not only is it nonsense it's
idiotic nonsense
so Farhad Manjoo who is a was replete
with idiotic nonsense he has a piece
today where he says all it took was a
pandemic of potentially unprecedented
scale and severity and suddenly it's
like we're turning into Denmark over
here in the last few days a parade of
American companies that had long
resisted providing humane and necessary
benefits to their workers abruptly
changed their minds announcing plans to
pay and protect even their lowest rung
employees harmed by the ravages of
coronavirus ok first of all that would
not be the government so where's the
socialism all right if Mark Cuban the
head of the Dallas Mavericks the owner
if he'd suggest that he's gonna come out
of pocket and make sure that furloughed
workers get paid what does that do at
the government the answer is nothing so
how is that Denmark e'en uber and lyft
which are currently fighting state
efforts to force them to pay benefits to
drivers and other gig workers announced
that actually a form of paid sick leave
wasn't such a bad idea overall again
these are private companies drivers who
contract the new virus or are placed in
quarantine will get paid for up to two
weeks said uber why are they doing that
because they don't want the
responsibility of a driver going out
there and then getting the passenger
sick and then ubers on the hook Trader
Joe's says it will cover for time off
for the virus again all of these are
private companies what the hell does
that have to do with government with
government intervention he's not even
like he's such an idiot he's not even
citing instances of government
intervention of which there aren't
plenty it wasn't just sick leave
overnight workplaces around the country
were transformed into Scandinavian
Eden's of flexibility can't make it to
the office because your kid has to
unexpectedly stay home from school last
week it sucked to be you this week what
are you even doing asking go home be
with your kid again voluntary action by
Provident he's proving the exact
opposite what he thinks is proven
private industry is acting responsibly
in many ways in order to minimize the
risk of the spread of this virus more
responsibly than the dams government
which has been lacks in nearly every
respect on this thing lagged a month
behind and didn't get the testing kits
out anywhere so I mean if anything this
column is proving the private industry
is doing the crap that government has
been unable to do thus far doesn't mean
the government is unnecessary government
is very necessary when it comes to
providing the testing kits although
private labs by the way are the ones
that are gonna have to ramp up
production in order to make sure that
those testing kits are available but
it's just amazing that you can conflate
private voluntary action with government
action then call it Denmark pretty
amazing then here here's where Farhad
Manjoo finally gets the government
program says the Trump administration
last seen proposing to slash a pay raise
for federal workers and endorsing a
family leave policy that doesn't
actually pay for family leave is now
singing the praises of universal sick
pay when we tell people if you're sick
stay home
the president has tasked the team with
developing economic policies that will
make it very very clear we're gonna
stand by those hardworking Americans
vice-president pence said on Monday
offering the sort of rhetoric that
wouldn't be out of places on the page of
Jacobin okay the difference is you're
talking about a widespread pandemic it
is very difficult to determine whether
people are truly sick or whether they
are truly not if you're talking about
government provide paid sick leave okay
this has been a serious problem in terms
of American disability a huge number of
Americans who are on disability are not
actually disabled right there are people
who claim disability and then they are
on disability because they say they have
back pain or something disability frauds
a serious problem now in a pandemic
the answer is ok well the risk is the
risk of people coming into work is a lot
higher than the risk of people
defrauding the system you got to keep
people home even if it means that you're
paying some people to fraudulently stay
home but that's because the risk factors
change to idiot representative Ted Yoho
Republican from Florida said you can
look at it as socialized medicine but in
the face of an outbreak of pandemic
what's your options as I said it's
almost funny everyone's a socialist -
pandemic yes and everyone is more of a
socialist in wartime Collective
reactions are necessary for collective
threats but medicine is not a collective
threat you having an individual case of
a particular disease that is not
communicable is not a matter of
everybody's interest financially that
doesn't mean there aren't all sorts of
things that we can do as a society and
as communities to make sure that people
get health insurance we can but to
pretend that all situations are equal is
the idiocy of the simple-minded to
pretend that pandemic situations are
equivalent to non pandemic situations
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous on its
face but that's what Farhad Manjoo does
for a living okay one more thing that I
hate so Mara gay who is one of the
leading forces behind the 16 and 19
project and who was a leading factor in
the myriad mistakes of the 1619 project
the other week we were making fun of her
but really making fun of Brian Williams
who's Brian Williams brought the tweet
MSNBC and the tweet on MSNBC suggested
that Michael Bloomberg could have paid
everybody a million dollars and still
had money left over he could paid
everybody in the United States a million
dollars for as much money as he spends
on the campaign that of course is not
true
hey Maura gay was there she left him
long he sort of laughed at her a little
bit but I said I'm the show that's not
Maura gays fault like I feel kind of bad
for her honestly because the fact is
that she's just a guest which gonna
fact-check Brian Williams in real time
hey but because people were making fun
of her now we get a full column from
Maura gay in the New York Times talking
about how it's racist to make fun of her
for scoring things up okay as somebody
who has been made fun of for screwing
things up at before let me just say that
um that's just called life that's called
life but Maura gay literally wrote a
piece for the New York Times called my
people have been through worse than a
Twitter mob when you're a black woman in
America with a public voice a trivial
math error can lead to a deluge of hate
spare me spare me the hysterics Maura
gay you're a member of the Editorial
Board of the New York Times you're on
national TV you screw it up it wasn't a
big deal people kind of made fun of it
that was it and yes there are always
idiots we're gonna send you nasty hate
mail I've gotten more nasty hate mail I
would bet bye-bye scores then anybody at
the New York Times editorial board but
the idea that my people have been
worried through worse than it for me yes
I'm fairly well aware that black people
in America have been through a lot worse
like slavery and Jim Crow then you're
taking a little bit of heat for making a
dumb mistake on MSNBC but to suggest
that like this is anywhere on par or
that this is racist it's such a New York
Times it's such a New York Times like
Brian winds got hit for this too he's
white but Maura gay says on MSNBC's the
eleventh hour with Brian Williams the
night before we mentioned it to be
written by someone else about the
enormous amounts of money Michael
Bloomberg had spent on his failed
presidential run about 500 million
dollars here's what I said somebody
tweeted recently that actually with the
money he spent he could have given every
American a million dollars the math as a
few people have pointed out was wrong
overnight I'd become an online sensation
and not in a good way the video had gone
viral first shared by the right-wing and
then by seemingly everyone else to some
people seemed surprised I couldn't
fact-check arithmetic on live TV let me
assure you my high school math teachers
were not among those people given my
history with math I thought the flub was
pretty funny I tried to laugh it off
buying a calculator I wrote on Twitter
on Friday be right back
in a normal time that would
the end of it but the country has lost
his mind so instead it was only the
beginning
okay well no it kind of wasn't like she
says across social media right-wing
trolls celebrated the next time they
make a mistake I hope people are nicer
to them than they were to me how did
this end up on TV one of them helpfully
wrote sharing the video unfortunately
quite a few Americans can tell you what
it's like to be the target of a Twitter
mob over a gaffe my great sin was
trivial harmless and silly what's it
like when people are trying to cancel
you for a math mistake
weird and maddening and painful can
nobody nobody was there small person who
suggested Mario guy should be fired over
the math mistake like anyone the answer
is no but she says of course in my case
it wasn't really about math as anyone
who read through my mentions on Twitter
or saw my inbox would know you're a
great example of why we need to end
affirmative action someone named Jim bee
wrote me in an email this weekend get a
job scrubbing floors it's the only thing
you're good for okay so now she's just
gonna go through her mailbox and find
all the races in her mailbox this is the
easiest game in the world if I found you
all the anti-semites in my mailbox I
could do full shows just reading the
anti-semitism in my mailbox
guess what who cares but these sort of
self sacrificial woe is me I'm a heroine
of the movement because I'm a black
person on TV and therefore any criticism
of me as criticism of blackness as
opposed to me making a dumb math mistake
again I thought the reaction was
overwhelmingly stupid tumhare gays dumb
mistake but to suggest that it's because
of overwhelming American racism it's
ridiculous many of those Americans she
says when she says when I appeared on
that TV program last week I've been
working for many days interviewing black
voters in the South for determined to
defeat Donald Trump who may see as the
nightmare embodiment of the old hatreds
many of them fought to overcome many of
those Americans had survived far worse
under the racial terror of Jim Crow than
anything I can imagine I thought about
the black man I met at the march across
the Edmund Pettus Bridge in Selma
Alabama hood and beaten bloody by the
police there half a century ago I
thought about the older black woman who
approached me at a summit coffee shop I
thought about my father who grew up in
during the daily indignities have
segregated South Carolina and Detroit
I'm here because of them and there's
nothing the haters can do about it okay
was anybody our again with that like
seriously who's who's arguing with that
and why are you comparing yourself to
that it's not the same thing at all a
self-pitying of oh I made a mistake on
TV people made fun of me it must be
because of my race you can always find
idiots to say things you can always find
it is to say things seriously not hard
already
well we'll be back later today with two
additional hours if my voice holds up if
not then we will be back here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
president Trump addresses the corona
virus epidemic from The Oval Office we
will examine how we're all gonna die
then Murray refuses to drop out of the
race a mathematically challenged New
York Times editorial board member cries
racism when people correct her and aoc
says it's racist not to eat lo mein all
that plus the mailbag check it out on a
Michael Knowles show
[Music]